madame monsieur bonjour et bienvenue
pour une nouvelle édition spéciale de la
Voix est libre consacrée à la fusion des
régions Bourgogne et Franche-Comté nous
sommes installés au sein de l'Université
de Bourgogne Franche-Comté qui est un
peu pré figuratif en termes de fusion
nous sommes précisément à la
bibliothèque universitaire sur le campus
de Dijon pour une émission que j'ai le
plaisir de coanimer avec vous au silence
bonjour
Eric bonjour à tous Dans cette émission
et bien on va poser des questions
concrètes sur les conséquences de la
fusion des régions pour le milieu
économique pour le monde de la recherche
de l'Université des transports du sport
de la culture et pour répondre à ces
questions et bien nous avons le plaisir
d'accueillir sur ce plateau les deux
présidents actuels des régions Bourgogne
Franche-Comté le président de Bourgogne
de François Patriat bonjour merci d'être
avec nous et la présidente de
Franche-Comté marigitte Dufay bonjour
merci d'être avec nous et je précise que
vous pouvez également candidate
socialiste pour les prochaines élections
régionales et aujourd'hui et bien Eric
on va pas dire grand chose finalement
puisque ce ne sont pas nous nous
n'allons pas poser les exactement pour
vous interroger on a réunit une dizaine
de personnes qui sont tous acteurs dans
l'un ou l'autre des domaines de
compétences des conseils régionaux alors
ils sont l'universitaires étudiants
lycées un syndicaliste chef d'entreprise
directeur de fersival ou organisateurs
d'événements sportifs et tout sont
beaucoup de questions à vous poser et
puis à la maison n'hésitez pas vous
aussi vous pouvez réagir aux propos qui
seront tenus pendant cette émission via
Twitter hashtag lvlbfc ou sur notre page
facebook allez on commence c'est quand
même moi qui vais poser la première
question est-ce qu'on peut faire un
point avec vous sur la fusion des deux
régions où est-ce qu'on en est
aujourd'hui
elle m'a réglisse Dufay
nous en sommes à ce que nous avions
prévu c'est à dire faire en sorte de
faire un état des lieux précis de toutes
les politiques qui nous qui nous que
nous conduisons de façon à voir comment
dans l'avenir harmoniser toutes ces
politiques et surtout faire en sorte que
en 2016 dès janvier 2016 tout fonctionne
bien dans la nouvelle région quelle que
soit l'équipement place que les salaires
puissent être versés correctement et que
les choses suivent en termes de
logistique donc cela avance c'est de la
cuisine interne mais en même temps nous
avons mis en place des commissions de
travail entre élus entre élus
bourguignon et élu franc-comtois pour
qu'ils suivent tous ces travaux en
sachant que nous n'allons pas harmoniser
toutes nos politiques dès le premier
janvier 2016 que par contre il est
important d'anticiper un certain nombre
de choses et c'est ce que nous sommes en
train de faire pour que nos partenaires
qu'ils soient économiques de des
formations du monde de la culture et du
sport ne soit pas inquiet
à l'arrivée des premiers mois de 2016
nous allons anticiper pour voir comment
sécuriser leur manifestation leur
programme pour le début de l'année 2016
François patriar vous la sentez avant
d'entrer dans la technique directement
moi j'aimerais rappeler que le processus
que nous avons initié avec marie-gite
sur lequel aujourd'hui il me semble
qu'une grande majorité des habitants des
deux régions sont favorables d'après ce
que je vois y compris d'ailleurs les
candidats aujourd'hui de l'opposition
qui ne conteste pas la fusion et qu'il
accepte et qui vont même la venter ce
que je voudrais dire c'est que c'est
quand même l'histoire qu'on écrit
actuellement avant d'être techniques
c'est d'abord l'histoire l'histoire de
deux régions complémentaires de deux
régions amis qui se sont souvent défiés
et qui vont écrire un destin commun pas
dans un but politique mais dans le but
d'améliorer le fonctionnement de leurs
institutions et dans le but d'améliorer
le sort des habitants dans des régions
c'est ça je crois le premier processus
et P c'est comme ça que nous devons
l'engager et le mener à bien les
personnes qui sont là justement ont
quand même quelques questions par
rapport au fonctionnement futur
technique et humaine alors vous dites
que les que les habitants sont
relativement favorables on va voir ça
avec Fabien maitre bonjour alors vous
vous êtes étudiants en 3e année en
Information Communication vous vous
apprêtez à entrer en master
communication politique justement et
vous vous intéressez donc à cette fusion
des régions avec quand même un certain
nombre de questions encore qui ne sont
pas éclaircies pour vous oui alors ma
première question moi était peut-être de
revenir pourquoi l'État a donc décidé de
fusionner les régions
ça sent pas forcément évident pas et
c'est pas évident pour tous les
habitants je pense de Bourgogne et de
Franche-Comté et même pour tous les
Français la première raison c'est de
donner une visibilité à nos grandes
régions à l'échelle de l'Europe
aujourd'hui un pays il a besoin au
niveau de l'Europe de monter des
stratégies avec les autres pays et nous
avons besoin au niveau de nos régions de
les faire monter et en compétences et en
taille donc le premier objectif c'est
une visibilité au niveau de l'Europe
faire des grandes régions comme dans les
régions voisines je pense que le
deuxième objectif et j'y adhère aussi
c'est de faire en sorte que dans nos
institutions qui sont compliquées on
arrive aussi à maîtriser les budgets et
à faire des économies au moment où on
est face à une crise de l'endettement
public qui est importante alors en
parlant d'économie vous nous dites que
ça va faire des économies la fusion des
régions mais il est annoncé un chiffre
de 25 0 millions d'euros que cette
fusion va coûter alors
où sont les économies
au niveau des déplacements des
fonctionnaires inexorablement le
processus entraînera des rapprochements
entraînera des structures plus efficaces
et plus économes alors le coût au jour
le jour moi je vais pas faire une
démarche notariale ce que je sais c'est
que le processus que nous avons engagé
il est guidé par deux principes le
principe de l'efficacité et le principe
de l'économie à moyen terme ou à long
terme à court terme dans l'immédiat je
ne l'ai pas chiffré comme tel ce que je
sais c'est que nous travaillons déjà
beaucoup plus ensemble c'est que nous
rapprochons nos politiques l'intérêt
c'est quand même malgré tout d'avoir
demain des transports plus efficaces des
universités plus complémentaires une
santé bien protégée des formations
professionnelles mieux réparties et
demain aussi plus en rapport avec la
demande c'est ça l'objectif alors si on
commence à avoir une vision notariale en
disant oui mais au début ça veut dit que
moi combien ça ça va coûter madame
celui des aéroports mais déjà celui-là
aujourd'hui il est déjà économe donc
prenons le cocktail et ne nous arrêtons
pas sur des sur des principes j'allais
dire j'ai dit notario parce que alors on
avancera pas
l'économies je dirais quand même
qu'elles sont déjà engagées et que la
Bourgogne comme la Franche-Comté sont
dans le plan national de de d'économie à
fournir nous avons dans les deux années
qui viennent entre la Bourgogne et la
Franche-Comté 40 millions d'économies à
rendre à l'état nous en avons fait
chacun l'année dernière plus de 10
millions
oui mais ce que je veux dire c'est
qu'avec la fusion 40 millions
d'économies en deux ans pour Bourgogne
Franche-Comté c'est quand même énorme et
si nous vous nous voulons que ces
économies n'impacte pas les politiques
et donc les services que nous rendons
aux citoyens et bien il vaut mieux être
deux pour affronter ces économies que
rester seul on est juste d'accord que
pour l'instant à l'échelle par exemple
la échéance de 2016 il y aura un budget
de la Franche-Comté un budget de la
Bourgogne et ça sera plus plus on va pas
pour l'instant mutualiser les moyens
dans les contrats de plans en tout cas
c'est comme ça que c'est prévu ah non il
y aura un seul budget et on est déjà en
train de les préparer c'est l'ajout de
la Bourgogne et de la Franche-Comté où
est-ce qu'il y a déjà des économies à
l'échelle de ce budget de toute façon
les économies elles sont elles sont
inhérentes nous venons de faire 10
millions d'économies dans l'année qui
vient de s'écouler nous en avons 20
millions chacun à faire dans les deux
années qui viennent donc ça fait partie
inhérente de la construction du budget
or A2 ça va être plus facile de comment
dire de digérer ces économies que seul
parce qu'on va mutualiser des moyens qui
vont nous permettre de faire des
économies et l'important c'est de ne pas
impacter les services qu'il n'y ait pas
moins de formation qu'il n'y ait pas
moins de train qu'il n'y ait pas moins
d'offre culturelle malgré les 40
millions d'économies que d'ici deux ans
Bourgogne et Franche-Comté doivent faire
vous parlez des communistes on va
justement parler de développement
économique puisque c'est l'une des
principales missions le moteur justement
de la nouvelle région Renan Oséo vous
êtes de belles formes bonjour vous êtes
directeur de la société voxelia vous
faites notamment de la maquette 3D et
bien vous avez des interrogations
quelles sont vos craintes justement vos
attentes de la nouvelle région alors
déjà nous en termes de d'intervention de
la région on situe à deux niveaux d'une
part cette valoriser déjà les filières
d'excellence et identifier les
compétences qu'il y a sur sur un
territoire donc c'est vrai que c'est
important à notre niveau parce qu'on
oppose souvent les gens aux entreprises
et notamment aussi de faire la confusion
entre les petites PME et les grands
groupes alors que c'est des enjeux
totalement différent etc donc c'est
vraiment sur ce premier plan qu'on voit
au quotidien du moins que il y a une
valorisation et le deuxième le deuxième
plan c'est le soutien en trouvant un
cadre de collaboration donc si je prends
mon exemple c'est notre PME de pouvoir
collaborer avec un géant comme Alstom et
de fournir un cadre à travers justement
des projets de collaboration ma question
elle est très simple c'est quid de la
fusion comment ça va ça va se passer par
rapport à ça dans la mesure où comme on
disait avant en termes de budget est-ce
qu'il va y avoir une mutualisation des
moyens ou est-ce que au contraire on va
on va chercher sur la complémentarité
des deux régions enfin voilà c'est
vraiment l'inquiétude je dirais qu'on a
au niveau des des entreprises en général
donc j'aimerais avoir votre sentiment
là-dessus
avant que je ne laisse la parole à
François Patriat je voudrais dire que
tous les deux nous avons dit dès le
début que ce qui devait être le moteur
de cette fusion c'était le développement
économique nous sommes absolument
convaincus que à deux nous serons plus
fins plus fort pour accompagner les
chefs d'entreprise parce que c'est pas
nous qui créons la valeur ajoutée c'est
vous qui l'a créé mais nous sommes là
pour vous favoriser l'environnement le
meilleur qui soit pour amener des
capitaux dans les entreprises et nous
avons des projets en termes de fonds de
développement de fonds d'investissement
pour les entreprises qui nous permettent
nous allons les multiplier aujourd'hui
nous avons décidé que nos fonds
d'investissement seraient comme un c'est
la première traduction de la fusion et
en ayant des fonds communs nous avons
des fonds supérieurs et nous nous dotons
d'une force de frappe en direction des
entreprises qui est plus importantes et
puis l'épaule d'excellence vous avez
cité le Nord Franche-Comté Nord
Franche-Comté c'est les fort c'est
l'énergie ce pôle d'excellence va faire
partie des pôles d'excellence de la
Grande Région et notre souci il va être
de renforcer ce qui est pôle
d'excellence autour du Creusot autour
d'un hivernais autour du Nord
Franche-Comté autour de Besançon donc ce
sera le moteur de la grande région alors
d'abord je voudrais rappeler à notre ami
qui cette région que la plus grosse
agglomération de la Bourgogne
Franche-Comté c'est
Belfort Montbéliard 300 000 habitants
donc ne penserons pas toujours en termes
de rivalité pensons en termes de
complémentarité deuxième réponse
la compétence essentielle demain de la
région à côté des transports et des
lycées c'est la dimension économique la
loi neutre va renforcer le pouvoir
économique des régions elle va le
renforcer d'abord dans les compétences
mais aussi dans les moyens il nous
attendons de la réforme qui doit des
fiscales qui doit arriver dans le budget
prochain des ressources supplémentaires
pour mieux accompagner l'économie je
vous rappelle que les petits entreprises
les moyens sont elles aussi tributaires
des grands groupes on voit bien ici dans
notre territoire comment ils sont
donneurs d'ordre pour beaucoup de même
que l'aéronautique l'aéronautique les
grands groupes sont donneurs d'ordre
d'autres régions donc il n'y a pas
d'opposition pour nous entre les deux
nous intervenons plutôt sur les TPE les
PME et les entreprises intermédiaires
donc je pense que nous aurons des moyens
supplémentaires des compétences
supplémentaires et une vision
supplémentaire parce que je rappelle
celui qui interrogé avant que l'histoire
de la fusion c'est pas 2014 elle date de
1967 ou des gens comme Duhamel pensait
déjà qu'il fallait faire la fusion à
l'époque donc on voit bien qu'il y a
cette nécessité et dans un domaine que
vous connaissez bien le domaine des
transports celui de la voiture de demain
on voit bien qu'il y a demain des
complémentarités donc de ces
complémentarités naîtront des
opportunités qui vont permettre aux
entreprises soit existantes soit en
création de trouver auprès de la région
un interlocuteur de proximité capable de
répondre pour partie à leur demande
revenons zéro on parlait de lisibilité
de lisibilité avant mais enfin déjà que
on est dans un contexte de déséquilibre
de territoire entre Franche-Comté Nord
et puis
différentes enfin composantes de la
Franche-Comté comment ça va se passer en
terme justement déséquilibre pourquoi
déséquilibre le Nord Franche-Comté c'est
le poumon économique de la Franche-Comté
dans la mesure où en fait on a une
lisibilité différente en fait on a des
activités il y a une identité
industrielle et économique qui est
différente cette cette identité qui est
différente entre Besançon entre Nord
Franche-Comté d'autres d'autres régions
enfin d'autres zones de la peut compter
comment ça va se passer justement en
fusionnant avec la Bourgogne qui elle a
aussi d'autres composantes et identités
mais la diversité des pôles d'excellence
de la région ne doit pas créer la
confusion vous dites il y a du
déséquilibre je dis qu'il y a de la
diversité et qui doit y avoir
enrichissement à partir de cette
diversité le pôle de de
péjoratif
économique le poumon industriel que
représente le Nord Franche-Comté il sera
toujours le poumon industriel de la
Bourgogne Franche-Comté c'est pas parce
que il est
omarge et qu'il est accolé à l'Alsace et
qu'il est à une extrémité de la Grande
Région ça ne change rien les courants
d'affaires qu'il y a entre le Nord
Franche-Comté et l'Alsace il
continueront il y a aucune raison ce qui
existait existera toujours je parle en
termes de lisibilité d'affichage bien
évidemment
regarde qu'on veut qu'on peut avoir sur
la Grande Région demain quand on pense
pour gagner Franche-Comté on pense
patrimoine environnement ruralité
territoire rural magnifique or il faudra
on va pouvoir affirmer demain et on nous
l'avons dit au chef de l'État avant-hier
que la région Bourgogne Franche-Comté va
être par habitant la première région
industrielle de France vous rendez
compte attendez par habitant d'ailleurs
le nombre d'emploi industriels ramener
au nombre d'habitants va en faire on
pourra parler comme ça on pourra
exprimer cela demande donc ça doit
rentrer d'abord j'allais dire dans
l'esprit des Francs couteau à des
Bourguignons avant de rentrer dans
l'esprit des Français par ailleurs d'où
une autre attractivité concrètement une
question toute bête est-ce que par
exemple pour les chefs d'entreprise qui
parfois doivent se rendre à Besançon
pour trouver des interlocuteurs au
niveau de la région est-ce que là ils
devront par exemple se rendre à Dijon
demain ou est-ce qu'il y aura justement
des interlocuteurs est-ce qu'il y aura
une espèce d'interface plus proche de
tous ces territoires qui sont du coup
forcément
tout va se faire avec une nouvelle
technique de communication on a créé IB
Bourgogne va venir de maïs Bourgogne
Franche-Comté tout va être dématérialisé
les demandes d'aide de l'accompagnement
la formation avec des briques
différentes qui permettent aujourd'hui
d'avoir un interlocuteur unique donc ça
va se faire de maths de cette façon la
d'où l'intérêt d'avoir demain des
dorsales des dorsales en fibres
intéressantes pour que ça puisse
fonctionner et un levier important du
développement économique sur lequel nous
nous pouvons agir nous au niveau de la
collectivité régionale c'est l'export
c'est l'aide à l'export or les salons
l'accès au salon c'est quelque chose qui
est très cher en unissant nos forces
d'autant plus que la Bourgogne a une
expérience très forte des salons
internationaux je pense que là on a un
plus et c'est un levier très important
pour les entreprises alors laissez
encore la parole à nos invités Frédéric
Marion secrétaire régional de la CFDT et
justement aussi une question à propos du
développement économique les territoires
oui bonjour ma question porte sur la le
peuplement très disparate avec des zones
très peuplées et des déserts relatifs
il a beaucoup de Franche-Comté certains
interco risquent de ne pas avoir la
taille critique
ma première question c'est va-t-on à
poser une taille unique ou alors va-t-on
obtenir compte de la réalité des
territoires en donnant plus à ceux qui
ont le moins au nom d'une solidarité
régionale
ça s'appelle la différenciation ce que
vous demandez alors vous me dites ça va
être un territoire disparate
les États-Unis vous connaissez c'est pas
un territoire monolithique unique il y a
aussi des territoires avec des grandes
villes carrière tous les pays du monde
en tout cas même tous les pays européens
sauf ceux qui sont très concentrés comme
la Hollande ou la Belgique n'ont pas de
non cette disparité donc moi je pense
que c'est un atout je vous rappelle que
beaucoup de pays européens ce qu'il nous
envie c'est l'espace et nous parce que
nous avons de l'espace ça deviendrait à
handicap donc je crois aussi que tu es
dans les têtes qu'il faut que ça change
aujourd'hui alors la différenciation
faut-il aider plus les territoires pour
on l'a fait naturellement aujourd'hui
quand il y a des projets porteurs dans
les territoires qui sont un peu plus
désertifiés un peu plus éloignés j'étais
la semaine dernière dans le canton de
Liernais voir une seule entreprise et
oui ce qui était là qui dit chemin de
câble on le fait naturellement et je
crois que les départements et les
régions et la région Franche-Comté comme
la région Bourgogne avaitillé avec
attention parce que les territoires en
difficulté puissent bénéficier non pas
d'une aide différentiellement accrue
mais d'un soin tout particulier pour
pouvoir maintenir les activités voir les
développer on parle de territoire on
parle détendu du territoire on va
forcément parler du coup transport
puisque c'est essentiel dans une région
et dans une grande région qui plus est
donnée la parole à François Janin vous
êtes porte-parole justement pour la
Fédération nationale des usagers du
transport pour la Franche-Comté et vous
avez je crois des interrogations sur
l'avenir justement et bien de certaines
lignes ferroviaires
je rappelle pour commencer que le budget
transport pour chacune des deux régions
est le budget principal après
l'éducation
avant même quelques fois avant
je voudrais dire que sur dans ce domaine
particulier des transports collectifs je
vais me limiter au ferroviaire et assez
de gens pour s'occuper des avions des
routes dans ce pays pour que je ne m'en
mêle pas alors au niveau du ferroviaire
nous ne partons pas situation égale le
handicap de la Franche-Comté est tel
qu'il faut en discuter avant de se
mettre d'accord je connais par cœur vos
deux contrats de plan état région celui
qui a déjà signé en Bourgogne cela qui
est en cours de signatures en
Franche-Comté sur vos priorités aux uns
et aux autres à la question que je me
pose et je vous la poser tel quel quid
de l'avenir d'une petite ligne comme
celle des hirondelles dol alors je vais
dire quand même mouchard Champagnole
Moret Saint-Claude c'est pas le désert
ça c'est un territoire remarquable à
tout point de vue économique touristique
humain qui vaut la peine d'être prise en
considération cette ligne là qu'est-ce
qu'elle pèse face à votre projet
monsieur Patriot voie Ferrer centre
europatlantique je comprends tout
l'intérêt de la vfce si je vous parle de
la réouverture de Belfort d'elle la
région a fait tout ce qu'elle pouvait
pour obtenir que les études soient
financées et payées il faut maintenant
que l'État apporte sa contribution pour
le faire nous sommes inquiets parce que
la somme elle est c'est vrai pour
Belfort donc je vais parler en résumé
donc les petites lignes vont faire les
frais vous craignez que les petites
lignes fassent les frais de ne pas
parler tout de suite de la ligne 4 la
fameuse ligne Paris la ligne des trains
d'équilibre du territoire qui dessert
Paris Vesoul belfort mulhouse
mardi prochain nous devons rencontrer le
ministre des Transports sa proposition
c'est de l'état de ramener à deux trains
seulement des paris Belfort alors que
nous pouvons nous faisons de la
démonstration que trois sont possibles à
coup égal or ça par exemple ce sont des
décisions qui dans la Grande Région va
nous aider à pousser ces dossiers là je
peux les multiplier
le représentant de la fenêtre vous
connaissez bien ces sujets
mais vous connaissez leur complexité et
vous savez que aujourd'hui Bourgogne et
Franche-Comté ont des conventions au
niveau des TER qui sont différentes et
bien pour vous montrer la bonne volonté
qui est la nôtre et la volonté de
construction et d'être positif c'est que
alors que tout nous amener à avoir des
conventions qui allaient s'éloigner
l'une de l'autre nous sommes en train de
tout mettre à plat pour avoir des la fin
de l'année prochaine une convention
unique donc ça veut dire que nous
prenons les moyens de nous écouter et de
voir ce qui est bon pour notre
territoire et ce qui est bon pour notre
territoire c'est d'avoir à la fois des
lignes à grande vitesse comme la ligne
effectivement vfcea et des lignes qui
servent qui irriguent les territoires et
je ne me suis pas battue comme je me
suis battue pour intégrer la ligne des
hirondelles dans le contrat de plan pour
que ça donne pour que demain cette ligne
des hirondelles n'existe plus donc
nous avons des intérêts communs parce
que cette région elle a besoin d'être
irriguée et demain il y aura plus la
Bourgogne d'un côté la Franche-Comté il
y aura ce grand territoire qui aura
besoin de vivre dans toutes ces
dimensions et qui aura besoin aussi bien
de grandes lignes que de petites lignes
irrigantes alors pour les pour les
usagers aujourd'hui regardez quand vous
voulez aller de Mâcon à Besançon vous
avez deux conventions différentes deux
tarifications différentes et bien dès le
1er janvier vous aurez une tarification
unique il y aura maintenant
aujourd'hui il y en avait deux
aujourd'hui elles seront harmonisées et
donc c'est l'intérêt des âgé demain
d'avoir passé ces deux conventions pour
les lignes Intercités vous avez raison
pour le problème est posé mais le
rapport du rond ne dit pas qu'il faut
supprimer tel ou telle il pose les
problèmes exemple Dijon Reims tout le
monde dit on va supprimer l'interdité de
Dijon Reims rappelez-vous une chose
c'est que cette Intercité il fonctionne
une fois par semaine les six autres
jours c'est les TER qui le font et ça
marche très bien et si Denis une fois un
vrai train enfin à grand un seul train
toi c'est du TER et ça marche très bien
donc là où le TER sera plus efficace que
l'intercité mettant du terrain on en
fait déjà aujourd'hui pour aller à Paris
ou ailleurs donc je crois qu'il faut
raisonner en terme conseiller régionaux
ceci dit sur la ligne 4 je pense qu'il
faut être vraiment très très prudent
parce que c'est une vraie ligne de
substitution à la ligne TGV en
Haute-Saône tout le monde effectivement
ne peut pas prendre le TGV à aller
prendre le TGV parce qu'il y a des
questions de discrimination tarifaire et
cette ligne 4 elle est très importante
pour la Haute-Saône et tout le monde de
tout bord se bat contre effectivement
les préconisations du rapport du rond
donc le combat il est clair et net il
est engagé sur les TER puisqu'on en a
parlé tout à l'heure aussi et puis que
François Patriat a parlé de
d'harmonisation des abonnements il y a
quelque chose que nous sommes aussi en
train d'essayer d'avancer au niveau de
la SNCF et là c'est vraiment concret
pour
tous ceux qui font les les trajets Dijon
Besançon ils sont nombreux d'aller
travailler dans les deux sens et les
trajets domicile travail sont importants
là c'est de faire en sorte que quand on
a un abonnement TER on puisse aussi
prendre le TGV parce que quand on a un
abonnement TER puis que le TER bah il
est en panne puis qu'on voit le TGV
arriver ben on pourrait le prendre et
puis on peut pas le prendre et on est en
train de faire bouger les choses à ce
niveau-là
est en train d'utiliser de savoir
comment elle va fluidifier demain entre
ces deux anciennes capitales la voix
nous on l'a déjà fait et ça nous a coûté
cher aujourd'hui disons Besançon c'est
une demi-heure c'est une demi-heure
quand on part de la gare d'Auxon vous
voyez on l'a déjà fait on a déjà avancé
thé vert sont très nombreux les terres
Besançon Dijon ils sont très nombreux
donc cette pluie elle existe mais c'est
votre mission
fluidité elle existe mais il y a une
complémentarité entre le TER et le TGV
qui n'existe pas et il faut absolument
que on fasse sauter ce verrou et je
pense que ça sera très concrètement plus
pour les usagers est-ce que ça veut dire
aussi au niveau du budget forcément un
effort supplémentaire au niveau de la
nouvelle région puisque tout ça un coup
bien évidemment il y a des choix à faire
et les transports ne devront pas faire
les frais des économies simplement aussi
bien en Bourgogne qu'en Franche-Comté il
y a des endroits aujourd'hui dans les
trains il y a très peu de monde et il y
a certains endroits où on peut remplacer
effectivement des déplacements les
desserts de ferroviaires à certains
moments de la journée à certains jours
de la semaine par des bus et ça ça fait
faire des économies et ces économies
elles nous permettent de maintenir par
ailleurs un service TER irriguant sur
toute la région
nous avons pris la décision dans le plan
d'économie que nous demande l'état
aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas touché aux
lignes transport ni aux lignes lycée
nioling formation professionnelle les
économies que nous faisons nous les
faisons uniquement sur le fonctionnement
et il n'est pas question de revenir sur
des conventions que nous signons avec la
SNCF aujourd'hui qu'ils ne peuvent pas
être revus à la baisse donc l'effort
sera poursuivi et continue je vous
rappelle que depuis 12 ans nous avons
diminué par deux l'âge des trains l'âge
des trains par 2 et que nous avons
amélioré les desserts François Patriot
il y a une question justement vous
parliez des lycées jour de la parole
après monsieur Janin juste à Clément
Toulouse qui est représentant de lycéens
ici puisqu'il fait partie du Syndicat
général des lycéens vous avez une
question à propos des transports bonjour
C'est concernant la on sait que en
Bourgogne en Franche-Comté il y a les
cartes jeunes avec des réductions on
sait qu'en Bourgogne il y a une
convention avec Paris où nous avons
aussi des réductions sur les transports
Bourgogne Paris je voulais savoir si
une nouvelle carte qui va harmoniser les
deux régions est-ce que est-ce qu'elle
sera nivelée vers le bas ou vers le haut
probablement au milieu probablement au
milieu mais on va aller vers cette
harmonisation effectivement et c'est
préférences tarifaires dont vous parlez
pour aller de Bourgogne à Paris et bien
à partir du moment où les abonnements de
Bourgogne seront harmonisés avec les
abonnements de Franche-Comté on va aller
effectivement vers une harmonisation
alors dire que tout se fera tarif égal
vient principe de réalité
Jean-Michel matheechro aussi vous
vouliez poser une question alors vous
êtes je vous présente directeur du
festival de musique de Besançon vous
avez une question justement sur les
cheveux par rapport aux transports à
cette problématique disons que je suis
usagé régulier de la ligne Lyon Besançon
tous les week-ends et c'est toujours un
peu étonnant dans de voir que le TER est
moins cher mais tout est plus rapide que
en prenant le TGV qui passe par par
Dijon alors est-ce que un jour vous
allez espoir que cette bout de ligne TGV
soit vraiment prolongée aille jusqu'à
son terme
veut dire jusqu'à Strasbourg d'un côté
jusqu'à Dijon de l'autre c'était un
petit peu ce que vous avez dit tout à
l'heure je parle du vétérinaire
on y travaille on y travaille mais cela
passe par des investissements
conséquents et aujourd'hui vous savez
qu'au niveau national ces
investissements ont été gelés donc moi
personnellement en tant que présidente
de la région de Franche-Comté avec
l'appui de du président de l'Alsace et
du président de la Bourgogne je
travaille à ce qu'en 2017 quand il y
aura une
réouverture de négociation sur ce qui a
été fermé et bien on puisse avancer au
moins en direction de Mulhouse dernière
question sur le sujet ne pas profiter
d'une tribune comme celle-là pour ne pas
défendre les liaisons transfrontalières
le partenaire économique principal de la
Franche-Comté c'est la Suisse on a des
points de France on a des points de
passage frontaliers à Vallorbe au
lockshop fond et Adèle qui valent
vraiment que toute la Grande Région se
met derrière nous pour pousser ses
dossiers qui sont majeurs
accessible
ou non moi je voudrais dire que derrière
les paroles de de François Janin
j'entends une espèce de méfiance
c'est-à-dire qui dit en gros la
Franche-Comté s'est battue pour
développer ses liaisons frontalières et
c'est vrai et demain ce qu'elle va
pouvoir continuer à se battre et je dis
demain il y aura ce grand territoire ça
sera plus la Bourgogne d'un côté la
Franche-Comté de l'autre et ça suffira
surtout pas l'un contre l'autre ça sera
la nécessité d'avoir un territoire qui
vivent bien qu'il soit équilibré et tout
l'art que jurassien tout l'art que
transfrontalier sera parti prenante de
la richesse de cette grande région donc
forcément nous serons attentifs à cet
aspect pas simplement au niveau
transport mais cela fera partie comme on
disait tout à l'heure de la diversité au
niveau économique tout là que se
transfrontalier ça va être une richesse
énorme pour la future grande région on
parlait de la Bourgogne Franche-Comté il
y a déjà eu une fusion Bourgogne
Franche-Comté au niveau de l'université
on va parler à présent justement de tout
le de la recherche de la formation de
l'université je vais passer la parole à
laurentric bonjour vous êtes maître de
conférence justement à l'université de
Franche-Comté et vous avez forcément des
questions à poser vos deux présidents
oui bonjour merci
je voulais revenir sur la notion de
d'économie qui implique des choix des
priorités et est-ce que vous pourriez
préciser nous préciser quels seront les
choix en matière d'innovation sur le
territoire puisqu'on sait que nos deux
régions financent les établissements
d'enseignement supérieur et la recherche
largement et demain quels seront les
choix et les priorités donc sur le plan
de la recherche et aussi ma seconde
question concernera la formation
professionnelle sur ce secteur là j'ai
envie de tout de suite de réagir en
disant s'il y a un secteur sur lequel il
doit pas y avoir d'économie c'est bien
celui-là tout à l'heure François Patriat
a dit très justement que la compétence
régionale elle a été renforcée dans les
années à venir et c'est bien
l'innovation qui permet de booster ce
développement économique donc nous
devons être aux côtés des acteurs de la
recherche nous sommes aux côtés des
acteurs de la recherche des acteurs de
l'enseignement sur un projet qui est
fabuleux le projet qui s'appelle is it
c'est un énorme projet que nos deux
universités sont en train de mener et
qui peut nous ramener dans les années à
venir plus de 30 millions d'euros pour
nos universités nous sommes
c'est une fusion ce sont des projets 30
millions
d'euros par an pour les universités qui
vont développer des projets à la fois
d'enseignement de recherche sur grand
trois grandes thématiques d'avenir la
santé l'alimentation les matériaux parce
qu'on est très fort dans ces domaines là
et ce que je veux dire c'est que nous
sommes en passe d'être lauréat au niveau
national sur ce projet il y avait 13
porteurs de projets il y en a plus que
trois nous sommes dans les trois et ce
que nous avons fait là si nous avions
été seuls nous n'aurions pas pu le c'est
vraiment l'université Bourgogne
Franche-Comté avec les deux régions
derrière qui est en passe effectivement
d'obtenir cette labellisation pour des
moyens conséquents et donc là on est
vraiment au coeur de l'innovation demain
à la recherche illénation sera seront le
facteur discriminant en terme
d'attractivité et nous avons en
Bourgogne en Franche-Comté et vous savez
madame réussit à mettre en place tous
les maillons de la chaîne de
l'innovation qui vont de l'émergence de
la détection de l'incubation du
financement avec les pépinières à côté
nous l'avons faitons nos deux sites et
demain je crois que alors que ça n'était
pas forcément notre compétence moi je me
souviens de devenu ici en 2004 en disant
tout converge ici tout commence ici à
l'université je l'avais dit parce que je
pense que c'est dans ce domaine
aujourd'hui que le
de demain l'attractivité de demain se
fera on le voit bien des sites comme
Grenoble reconnu comme tel aujourd'hui
ou même en Lorraine il y en a d'autres
aussi et bien nous avons cette non
seulement cette ambition mais nous avons
déjà cette expérience et ce bilan en la
matière et personne ne penserait
aujourd'hui en matière d'université de
recherche d'innovation et tous les
responsables politiques voire
économiques qui viennent nous les
emmenons aujourd'hui sur les sites qui
permettent demain d'avoir cet effort
supplémentaire qu'il faudra développer
demain je partage tout à fait vos propos
de fait ma question la suite c'est
est-ce que les le soutien sera
exclusivement à ses grands projets ou
est-ce comment comment vous voyez les
les choses je pense qu'il y aura
continuité par rapport à ce que nous
faisons aujourd'hui et dans le soutien
que nous avons au projet de recherche
vous savez puisque vous connaissez le
domaine vous savez que nous sommes à la
fois sur des grands projets et aussi sur
des projets plus modestes ce qui est
important c'est que on renforce bien
fait l'excellence de cette région et de
cette future grande région et
l'excellence elle est sur l'énergie sur
les microtechniques sur l'alimentation
sur la santé notamment sur le biomédical
sur le luxe aussi et quand j'ai éliminé
énuméré tous ces domaines là on a quand
même des domaines qui au niveau mondial
son porteurs d'avenir parce que qui dit
transport dit mobilité c'est un sujet
énorme pour demain à tous les pays
émergents qu'il va falloir alimenter en
véhicules modernes hybride économe en
énergie c'est un marché phénoménal
l'alimentation la santé c'est un enjeu
primordial aussi bien sur ces domaines
alimentation santé que sur le domaine
des mobilités de l'énergie qui sont des
enjeux mondiaux nous avons des forces
d'avance donc il faut forcément on
mettra la priorité c'est une question
une question
plus simple tout bête je m'adresse
peut-être à ce moment-là à laurentric
que représente pour vous pour les
universités pour les chercheurs les
financements régionaux pour qu'on ait en
fait une idée de ce que représente
justement la région dans ce dans ce
secteur pour vous au niveau c'est quoi
c'est 5% 20%, 10% au niveau du des
projets par exemple de recherche une
école mais est-ce que ça veut dire que
la région je veux dire est voilà est
vraiment un moteur essentiel oui c'est
ça qu'il faut qu'on double on arrive
avec les crédits européens avec les
crédits européens avec les crédits de la
région et quand on parle d'isite avec
les crédits de l'État donc la part des
financements de la région elle varie
selon les projets parfois les plus
importants que d'autres parfois elle est
moins mais madame a raison de dire il
n'y a pas que la recherche fondamentale
et la recherche académique ça je crois
que c'est à tous de la soutenir
aujourd'hui pour ce qui est de la
recherche pratique industrielle
quotidienne tous les jours c'est là elle
va être aussi accompagnée à travers les
agences que nous avons créé quand nous
créons une agence régionale de
développement d'innovation pour
l'économie et le développement durable
nous allons aussi aider l'innovation qui
n'est pas qui n'est pas la recherche
fondamentale dans les petites
entreprises tous les jours et ça nous
l'accompagnons aussi il s'appuie ces
industriels sur l'université ils
s'appuie sur la recherche privée mais il
s'appuie aussi sur un ensemble de
financements et nous entendons nous
poursuivre c'est là aujourd'hui les
petits entreprises qui en ont besoin de
pouvoir les accompagner vraiment et tout
cela se passe notamment ici sur le
campus de Dijon où nous doute trouvons
pour cette émission spéciale consacrée à
la fusion des régions on va peut-être
continuer sur la formation
professionnelle vous vouliez en dire un
mot madame peut-être en commençant avec
le Frédéric le Marion si ça ne vous
dérange pas puisque Frédéric Marion est
aussi vice-président de de la coparée
enfin c'est une nouvelle instance c'est
le comité paritaire régional pour
l'emploi et la formation et donc vous
aviez des questions justement à ce
propos
oui donc
c'est à la formation je voulais revenir
d'abord sur ce qu'on évoquait tout à
l'heure mais je vais patrria vous
parliez du site
ibourgogne dématérialisés de
dématérialisation de
travail à distance enfin pour moi ça
m'est passé au travail à distance au
télétravail
voilà
les agences sont très inquiets
concernant la mobilité personnelle des
collectivités par rapport à la mobilité
par rapport à la
question télétravail par rapport à la
bonne équilibre de l'aménagement du
territoire
qu'avez-vous prévu en termes de
formation pour ces personnes pour ces
agents qui qui seront en situation de
mobilité ou qui ne vous souhaitent pas
être en mobilité
alors vous parlez des agents des
conseils régionaux qui vont
vous adressez à François Patriat et
c'est moi qui répond donc je m'excuser
mais je pense que il ne me c'est dans le
marbre ou est-ce que ça dépend du
candidat qui sera élu d'abord on a
rien qui est dans le marbre tout est
reconstruire tout est à construire donc
effectivement moi je m'en parle du micro
pour vous dire que d'abord François
Patriat et moi nous avons décidé une
chose c'est qu'il n'y aurait pas de
mobilité géographique imposée aux agents
de nos deux collectivités premièrement
après il y aura forcément des mobilités
puisque une grande réforme comme ça elle
se fait pas sans aucun changement sinon
ça sert à quoi de faire une réforme et
là forcément que les plantes formation
seront mis en oeuvre mais on en est pas
là encore ça c'est vraiment la nouvelle
équipe qui devra conduire ça on en est
pas là là où on en est c'est de faire en
sorte qu'il y ait dans les emplois
publics entre
Dijon et Besançon un équilibre ça
renvoie à l'organisation des services de
l'État si la préfecture est d'un côté
qu'est-ce qu'il y a de l'autre pour
faire équilibre du coup nous au niveau
du conseil régional on travaille de la
même façon de voir comment on pourrait
répartir nos services mais répartir nos
services ça veut pas dire par exemple si
la le service transport mettons est à
Dijon parce que Dijon est un grand neuf
ferroviaire on peut imaginer ça ça veut
pas dire que tous les agents du service
transport de Besançon vont partir à
Dijon c'est la direction qui sera à
Dijon mais les agents ils vont rester en
poste ne serait-ce que comme vous l'avez
dit on va pas faire du déménagement du
territoire vous avez parlé de principe
d'aménagement du territoire ma bien
falloir continuer d'administrer le
territoire et d'être dans la proximité
et d'ailleurs cette grande région qui
souvent inquiète mais il y a beaucoup
beaucoup de fantasmes derrière ces
inquiétudes on dit oh là là mais alors
la proximité va arrête tout va être très
loin on oubliant qu'aujourd'hui personne
ne se pose la question de savoir où est
la région où est le conseil régional
parce qu'en général quand même les
citoyens ne vont pas faire des démarches
au conseil régional mais moi je dis que
demain la grande région elle devra se
déconcentrer c'est à dire qu'elle devra
avoir alors j'ose pas dire des antennes
parce que ça a l'air de dire qu'on va
multiplier des structures il s'agit pas
de multiplier des structures mais c'est
dans notre capacité d'organisation il
faudra qu'on ait une organisation très
territorialisée parce que le rôle d'une
région c'est d'être au contact de
l'initiative l'initiative des
développeurs économiques l'initiative
des organismes de formation l'initiative
des gens de la culture du sport et pour
être le plus en contact possible
effectivement faudra qu'on ait une
organisation territoriale vous parlez
possible vous parlez de la formation va
justement peut-être passer le micro
alors on sait qu'il y avait une question
justement sur la formation
professionnelle oui
oui donc je suis du service formation
continue de l'Université de
Franche-Comté donc c'est pour ça que
j'interviens aussi dans à ce titre là
j'aurais aimé savoir la région de
Franche-Comté soutient le financement de
demandeurs d'emploi et elle les
priorités sont aujourd'hui les bas
niveau de formation et
les formations ciblées sur l'industrie
il me semble quand Bourgogne c'est la
même les mêmes orientations mais là je
n'ai pas toutes les données j'aurais
aimé savoir demain ce qui est envisagé
surtout dans un contexte où justement on
a besoin de développement économique de
de dynamiser de continuer à ce que ce
territoire soit dynamique et puis
également peut-être des inquiétudes sur
le type de formation c'est à dire des
formations ciblées dans l'industrie la
communication et peut de formation de
soutien des formations dans le domaine
des sciences humaines alors qu'on sait
combien aujourd'hui l'humain est au cœur
de du système voilà les questions mais
surtout une question d'équilibre
effectivement il faut arriver à être sur
tous les domaines parce que le
développement il n'est pas fait que
d'une seule composante il se trouve que
la Franche-Comté est très industrielle
donc son système de formation de
formation professionnelle et très liée à
l'industrie ça ne veut pas dire qu'il
faut oublier les autres matières mais
puisque le sujet c'est aujourd'hui que
la grand qu'est-ce que la Grande Région
va donner par rapport à ça je pense
qu'il va falloir et on est en train de
commencer à mettre à plat tous nos
systèmes de formation nos propositions
et le but c'est que demain on crée des
formations qui n'existent pas et qu'on
les crée pourquoi ben parce que on aura
une taille critique qu'on n'a pas
aujourd'hui il y a des formations qu'on
peut pas ouvrir parce que il y a pas
assez de demandeurs d'emploi vous l'avez
dit c'est la formation des demandeurs
d'emploi notre métier au niveau des
régions c'est la formation des
demandeurs d'emploi il y a des
formations qu'on peut pas ouvrir parce
qu'il y a pas assez de monde en étant
effectivement Unis il y a probablement
des formations qu'on pourra ouvrir puis
moi je pense au niveau de l'information
initiale qu'une grande région elle peut
pousser aussi à ce que des écoles qu'on
n'a jamais eu puisse exister je pense
notamment à une école d'architecture là
on est sur des choix politiques quand
même qui dépendront aussi du résultat
des élections on peut peut-être dire
aussi quand même juste pour conclure ce
sujet savoir jusqu'à quand les
passeports permis de conduire les aides
les bourses à l'emploi tout ce que vous
avez mis en place vous chacun dans
chaque région ça sera valable encore
combien de temps est-ce que ça s'arrête
au 1er janvier on a travaillé sur ces
sujets on va même voter des crédits pour
que l'essentiel je pense à l'économie
sociale et solidaire puisse avoir leur
budget sécurisé avant que la future
région vote leur budget donc on regarde
aujourd'hui vous savez qu'on a ouvert
270 chantiers sur lesquels on a regardé
ce que vous êtes tel ou telle région et
nous sommes parfois plus performants ou
plus dépensier ou inversement on va donc
regarder ce qui est le plus utile ce qui
est le plus efficace aujourd'hui notre
travail
en tout cas surtout pour qu'il me
concerne c'est de préparer les
conditions de la réussite demain
d'ailleurs de mettre les choses sur la
table de les évaluer en termes
d'efficacité mais aussi en termes de
côtes donc pour les formations madame là
vous avez raison il faut que nos
formations demain soient en réponse à la
demande professionnelle dans les
sciences aussi bien économiques
industrielles que les sciences humaines
où il y a des marges de manœuvre de
progression aujourd'hui donc pour la
formation c'est aussi un volume qui nous
diminuera pas je réponds dernière
question à Monsieur les personnels a
priori sont légitimement inquiets parce
que ça va changer bon 1 il ne perdront
rien personne ne perdra rien faudrait
quand même qu'on le rappelle ici mais
par contre il y a peut-être avec la
fusion des opportunités il y aura même
parfois des changements de métier des
gens qui voudront rester sur place mais
qui changeront de métiers à la région et
pour lesquelles on assurera les
formations il y a des gens qui est dans
la territorialisation seront peut-être
contentes se rapprocher du Jura
peut-être à côté de se rapprocher du
Haut-Doubs et qui vont pouvoir en
profiter aussi donc on va regarder les
opportunités
unifier les formations et répondre à la
demande de l'efficacité de l'appareil de
demain la rentrée que vous aviez une
dernière question je crois sur la par
rapport à ça par rapport à la formation
oui aujourd'hui les régions ont un rôle
important notamment dans la
l'établissement des listes éligibles au
compte personnels formation donc qui
concerne tout salarié et j'aurais aimé
savoir quel soutien de des deux régions
et de la future grande région sur les
formations du supérieur l'inscription de
nos formations sur ces listes éligibles
afin que tout un chacun puisse venir se
former
sur toute une partie de nos diplômes sur
l'ensemble
c'est un chantier qui s'ouvre donc on
commence à le à l'appréhender et on
l'appréhende ensemble il y a pas la
Franche-Comté d'un côté la Bourgogne de
l'autre sur cette question on
l'appréhende ensemble
alors avant le supérieur il y a le lycée
c'est aussi les lycées une des
compétences des conseils régionaux que
on va donner la parole à Clément
Toulouse qui est donc lycéen à Dijon qui
est très actif dans dans la vie lycéenne
aussi bien au niveau régional que
national alors je voulais reprendre sur
le les lycées professionnels donc vous
disiez que vous lui organiser le
territoire que il y ait pas de que des
territoires soient pas sans rien mais
vous avez annoncé trois fermetures de
lycée professionnel alors est-ce que ça
va pas centraliser sur les grandes
villes les formations et donc faire des
déplacements pour les lycéens et des
coûts supplémentaires
l'année dernière j'ai annoncé un plan de
1 milliard d'euros sur les lycées de
Franche-Comté pour les années à venir
et à la faveur de ce plan qui consiste
vraiment à mettre les moyens sur les
lycées de la façon la plus performante
possible nous avons vu qu'il y avait
trois lycées qui pouvaient poser
question alors non pas par rapport à
leur formation ce qu'il ne s'agissait
pas de fermer les formations mais de
fermer des lycées qui avaient des
conditions de travail plutôt obsolètes
au niveau des bâtiments qu'ils offraient
alors que la population était en baisse
c'était il y a un an
et nous avions dit que nous allions
expertiser cette question au bout d'un
an le milliard commence à se dépenser
c'est-à-dire que nous avons un plan
d'investissement sur nos lycées et au
final nous fermerons un lycée comment
pourquoi celui de qui est un lycée
professionnel à Besançon et si nous le
fermons c'est parce que c'est un lycée
où il y a vraiment une baisse
démographique très importante mais les
formations qui étaient dispensées dans
ce lycée elles vont être dispensées dans
un lycée qui est dans plusieurs lycées
mais majoritairement un lycée qui est à
300 mètres de ce lycée là
donc il ne faut pas attiser de crainte
et les lycées professionnels ça a été
pour la Franche-Comté compte tenu de son
caractère industriel une vraie priorité
nous les avons modernisés pour faire en
sorte qu'il soit des vitrines des
emplois de demain parce que
malheureusement en France comptait comme
dans le reste de la France on ne croit
pas qu'il y a un métier dans un avenir
dans les métiers de l'industrie et dans
les métiers techniques et ça
culturellement il faut que l'on
travaille la contre et je pense que
offrir des belles vitrines aux parents
et à leur enfant à travers ses lycées
professionnels des vitrines des métiers
de demain c'est aller dans le sens de
réconcilier les habitants avec les
métiers de l'industrie n'oublions pas
qu'on ne tient pas des structures dans
un territoire pour maintenir des
familles ou des emplois
on me fait des lycées dans l'intérêt des
jeunes
dans leur intérêt professionnel dans
leur avenir donc il y a une fermeture en
Bourgogne j'ai envisagé alors qu'elle va
se passer vous savez à la rentrée 2016
n'étant pas candidats j'aurais pu
m'économiser d'aller sur le territoire
je le fais parce que celui-ci de Joigny
aujourd'hui va voir 70 élèves un lycée à
70 élèves ok à 30 personnes 70 alors
qu'à Joigny il a il s'agit de glisser de
Migennes à Joigny il y a un lycée à 16
km qui a des places disponibles et à
Auxerre à 20 km de l'autre côté il y a
deux lycées qui peuvent accueillir les
lycéens donc je pense que il s'agit pas
de tirer tout vers les grandes villes il
s'agit de maintenir des petits lycées là
où ils ont leur raison d'être je pense
ici en Bourgogne à Châtillon-sur-Seine
pas des petits lycées des lycées qui ont
leur raison d'être territorialement et
en terme humain je voudrais rappeler
qu'en termes d'université on ne parle
pas assez université il y a des dents il
y a deux sites il y a deux sites
universitaires en Bourgogne que nous
entendons faire vivre tous parce qu'ils
ont tous leurs raisons d'être et leurs
forces rapidement vous allez encore une
question question en Bourgogne il y
avait le budget parti participatif des
lycées qui servait à nous fournir des
subventions pour faire des projets dans
chaque lycée de Bourgogne mais il a été
sub bah supprimé en 2014 on avait des
subventions entre 1000 et 5000 euros
selon le projet il a été supprimé en
2014 donc avec leur rectorat donne des
subventions mais pour financer certains
projets il manque des sommes d'argent
est-ce que dans la grande région il y
aura un budget pour les lycéens pour
favoriser l'émergence de projets dans
les lycées
le budget participatif c'est une
création de notre majorité qui a
pleinement réussi sa mission avec ceux
qui voulaient le faire il a pas été
supprimé complètement non il a été pour
certains allégés ou dans certains on a
défini un certain nombre de critères
alors maintenant il appartiendra au
futur
exécutifs de dire quel choix il fait en
termes parce que dans les lycées Marie 1
milliard maintenant c'est quelque chose
la région poursuivra son effort entre 40
et 50 millions d'euros pour la Bourgogne
mais les deux confondus demain se
rajouteront on va le poursuivre si
dedans on peut dégager une marge pour
qu'il y ait une partie de ces crédits
qui aille au budget participatif autour
de projets cohérents novateur innovant
je pense pas que la future majorité
surtout si elle est chez nous il
renoncer ça c'est fait on va passer au
domaine culturel si vous le voulez bien
la suggestion pour marier du fait au cas
où
on va passer à la culture à présent avec
Jean-Michel Mathe je rappelle vous êtes
directeur du festival de musique de
Franche-Comté à Besançon et vous avez
justement une interrogation sur la
future et bien place de la culture dans
la nouvelle région oui c'est vrai que
après les élections municipales beaucoup
de
scène ou de milieu de la culture ont
subi des baisses ou parfois même des en
subit des choses un petit peu
désagréables ou des choses ingérence
dans le projet culturel ou des des
choses assez brutales il y a également
la mobilisation de la modernisation de
l'État qui a pour effet avoir des
conséquences alors évidemment il y a
beaucoup d'inquiétudes dans le milieu
culturel j'entendu votre votre
propos qui rassurait en disant pour 2016
parce que calendrier est quand même très
défavorable avec les élections qui
arrivent en décembre donc voilà c'est à
dire que les votes de subvention et puis
les signatures de convention éventuelles
avec des avec des diffuseurs culturels
ou des ou des scènes ou des ou des
anciens artistiques et bien sont
différés donc j'entends votre propos
disant ça va être sécurisé en 2016 après
2017 qu'elle sera la place de la culture
dans la grande région est-ce que ça peut
être comme c'est malheureusement pas le
cas une variable d'ajustement avec des
coups de rabot un peu général en disant
bah voilà on a une baisse à tout le
monde à moins 10 - 15 ou est-ce qu'il y
aura des priorités qui peuvent être je
sais pas moi la création l'enseignement
la diffusion est-ce que vous avez déjà
peut-être en tant que candidate des
propositions ou des promesses ou des
engagements à nous faire peut-être aussi
spécifié si c'est bien inscrit dans la
loi neutre que la compétence culturelle
reste au Conseil régionaux il y a pas de
compétences culturelles ou conseil
régional il y en a pas et donc il y en a
pas et on va continuer comme avant
c'est-à-dire qu'il y en a pas et la
compétence culturelle normalement elle
est partagée
pour être prises par personne quelque
part elle est partagée entre toutes les
collectivités et l'État
la réalité aujourd'hui c'est que vous
avez une région la Bourgogne qui a un
budget culturel d'une très très grande
importance l'investissement sur la
culture en Bourgogne a été massif en
Franche-Comté il a été probablement
moins
mais en même temps nous n'avons pas
touché depuis plusieurs années à ce
budget nous l'avons quelque part
sanctuarisées parce que nous pensons
qu'effectivement la culture c'est un
mode à la fois de développement de la
région et de développement des personnes
la culture nous lui demandons deux
choses depuis une région c'est d'une
part qu'elle porte haut les couleurs de
la région il doit y avoir une
attractivité et vous en tant que
directeur du festival de musique de
Besançon vous participez de cette
attractivité de la région et puis en
même temps il faut conquérir conquérir
conquérir les publics il faut que cette
culture elle s'ouvre parce que tout le
monde n'a pas accès à la culture à la
connaissance des arts et donc c'est ces
deux choses que nous demandons
attractivité régionale et puis médiation
conquête démocratisation de la culture
sous ces deux critères moi je pense que
nous avons des batailles à mener qu'il
faut les mener pour maintenir les
enveloppes budgétaires
en Bourgogne en Franche-Comté
effectivement
elle est parfois même dépassant parfois
les publics qui peuvent qui peuvent y
assister elle est diverse elle est dans
les domaines de qualité de d'excellence
dans tous les domaines de la culture je
voudrais rappeler à Monsieur que il y a
pas eu de rabots dans les économies
générale les grosses structures ont été
un peu plus impactées nous on a pauvons
pas toucher aux petites structures
maintenant je m'interroge sur la
nécessité pour la collectivité régionale
d'aller continuer demain d'aider des
petits événements culturels dont je ne
nie pas l'intérêt local dont je n'ai pas
la mobilisation des bénévoles autour
mais qui sont aujourd'hui des événements
qui peut-être n'ont pas le public
nécessaire pour vivre de ma banque ça
veut dire malgré soi est-ce que ça veut
dire très concrètement c'est ce que
demandait un petit peu monsieur mater
est-ce que on fera des choix c'est à
dire qu'on effectivement on arrêtera de
subventionner des dés financièrement
certains événements culturels pour
justement pouvoir continuer à aider
d'autres événements il est trop tôt pour
vous dire ça
si vous connaissez pas je vous le
donnerai à la fin parce que c'est un
document qui essaie de donner un cadre
et gérer un code conduite entre les élus
et les acteurs culturels il faut savoir
que mieux culturels a besoin
d'anticipation on peut comprendre qu'une
collectivité doit faire des choix doit
être on a besoin d'anticiper je
travaille actuellement ce festival
2016-2017 2018 on ne peut pas aucune de
ces ensembles musicaux de ces orchestres
de ces même tous les autres acteurs de
la culture les scènes de musique
actuelle plus d'autres formes musicales
ou les scènes conventionnées ne peuvent
en cours d'année ou en fin d'année à
prendre que tout est arrêté pour l'année
suivante donc on peut comprendre des
choix même si on voudrait bien sûr ce
qu'on crée un peu c'est les notions de
mutualisation mais est-ce que voilà il
faut bien vous avez compris là on va pas
arrêter là dans un chemin
2017-2018 chaque chose en son temps on
est en train de parler de préparer une
fusion des régions et dans une
préparation dans cette dans cette
préparation on est en train de se dire
les structures pas que culturelles mais
enfin les enfants partis il y a aussi
tous nos partenaires de la formation ils
ont des événements ils ont des
manifestations dans les 6 premiers mois
de l'année ils ont aussi des besoins de
fonds de rôle roulement qui qui table
sur nos subventions or avec cette
nouvelle région il y aura pas de budget
avant au moins le mois de mai prochain
donc il faut les sécuriser et on est en
train de préparer chacun en Bourgogne et
en Franche-Comté les éléments
budgétaires pour la fin de l'année pour
sécuriser donc vous voyez je vous en
remercie c'est une très bonne décision
mais je dis pensez aussi à la deuxième
étape
chaque chose en son temps et je vous ai
répondu aussi sur deux
mais après c'est un peu le flou attendez
cette question serait question de
campagne électorale ce sera le programme
des candidats qui s'engageront on dit
voilà quel est votre quel est votre
programme culturel pour l'avenir ça ça
va être la campagne
mais en même temps c'est vrai que c'est
compliqué
tout le monde a envie de dire on
soutient la culture on soutient la
culture et personne ne va vous dire mais
oui voilà bon moi je dis il y a des
éléments qui doivent il y a des critères
très très importants je vous l'ai dit je
vous ai donné ces deux critères ce qui
participent au rayonnement de la région
de la Grande Région et ce qui permet de
conquérir les publics et c'est pour ça
que j'ai donné c'était exemple des
escales lyriques parce que quand je vois
cet ensemble de Justiniana qui depuis la
Haute-Saône va aller au fond d'une
hivernais et du haut doux pour préparer
des opéras avec les jeunes bon on vous
sent passionnés et je pense que la
question va être se posera aussi pour la
question sportive on l'abordera dans la
seconde partie de cette émission parce
que pour l'instant il va être midi lors
de faire une pause pour prendre
connaissance de l'actualité dans nos
dossier en Bourgogne et en Franche-Comté
on se retrouve dans environ cinq minutes
à tout de suite